ludovic de l'air merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on a vu le
chef de l'état aujourd'hui se déplacer
dans une usine de masques justement
pleine pénurie de ce moyen de protection
qu'est ce que ce déplacement révèle de
la volonté présidentielle selon vous
enfin déjà c'est le premier point c'est
que on ne peut qu'être content qu enfin
démarche que ce soit commandé qui
s'intéresse aux usines de masques
s'arrêter bien que l'on emporte 1 lors
de la visite
et enfin il prend des décisions qui sont
les décisions d'urgence qu'avait prise
il ya trois semaines
si ce n'est plus celui qui de courant
depuis janvier à prioriser fait le pari
de l'immunité totale pour tout le monde
ils auraient pu dès janvier commander
les masques et on les aurait déjà depuis
fin janvier s'est arrêtée un peu plus
préférable
donc on peut avoir une pensée déjà pour
les gens qui sont malades qui sont
malades testé pour tous les gens qui ne
sont pas question qu'ils sont chez eux
qu'ils ne savent pas ce qui leur arrive
et ils ne sont toujours pas testé parce
que les chiffres annoncés sont
évidemment les gens qui sont testés
officiellement au coronavirus ocvidh et
tous ceux qui ne savent pas par contre
sens dans une angoisse enfermés chez eux
donc il faut aussi avoir une pensée pour
eux quand ils voient ces images qui
chaque jour sont une escalade dans
l'indécence un peu plus
et puis c'est bien d'aller dans une
usine de masques quand la porte parole
du gouvernement dit que ça ne sert à
rien donc on est toujours le entre deux
on ne sait pas trop quoi penser on sait
pas trop quelle est la règle à adopter
on ne sait pas quel est le message clair
on n'a toujours pas de l'information qui
soit stable durable la part du
gouvernement sans ce qu'il fait mais sur
ce qu'il faut faire jour après jour donc
chacun se débrouille un peu comme il
peut et tous les réseaux de solidarité
se met en place
or l'état aujourd'hui vous parler
d'indécence qu'est ce qui pourrait être
un descendant la commune est dans la
communication c'est au gouvernement et
celle du chef de l'état alexis poulain
l'aventuré un peu plus tôt sur votre
antenne mais quand on parle de
souveraineté européenne déjà j'aimerais
bien qu'on m'explique ce que ça signifie
est ce que ce terme n'a aujourd'hui plus
aucun sens en réalité
et puis quand il dit que ça a été vite
je crois klein on est vraiment en plein
milieu de l'indécence de dire fin mars
que ça a été vite et que les premiers
les premières cargaisons de masques sont
arrivés alors qu'on a bradé les
précédents et qu'on a tardé pour passer
les commandes alors que c'est les
personnels soignants qui les demandent
depuis des semaines maintenant que ces
demandes et tous les jours à l'assemblée
un certain de l'éduquer qui se battent
pour ceux qui sont là ceux qui font pas
là qui ne sont pas confinés qui
continuent de faire leur travail quand
même certaines députés qui sont sur le
front médical et en plus sur le front à
l'assemblée et qui demandent ces masques
et tu demandes d'autres choses parce que
l'on ne parle que des masques mais ça
fait des jours qu'on annonce une peine
une pénurie de curare de sédatifs de
morphine d'antibiotiques que les
personnels soignants sont toujours pas
équipés et il va parader dans genesis
pour dire il ya des masques qui arrive
alors que les masques c'est déjà trop
tard
c'est déjà trop tard il faut déjà passer
aux commandes de produits
il faut nationaliser au plus vite lux
faire pour l'oxygène médical parce qu'on
en aura plus à la fin de la semaine
il faut plus rapidement nationaliser
fera marre parce que sont les seuls qui
peuvent produire les médicaments dont on
a besoin
donc si on attend encore un mois ce sera
trop tard parce qu'à la fin du mois n'y
a plus de morphine et antibiotiques dans
les hôpitaux alors ludovic de l'air je
vous parle ire de cette citation du du
président de la république et le deuil
des quand il a évoqué la souveraineté
européenne il a aussi évoqué est la
souveraineté française est ce que l'on
peut percevoir un tournant dans la
vision du chef de l'état à savoir un
retour au made in france
alors j'ai passé un retour au made in
france
il ya une gêne biotech qui est passé sur
votre antenne un peu plus tôt
effectivement c'est cette société
bretonne qui peut aujourd'hui fabriqué
des tests à grande échelle et qui
promettent un million de tests pour le
le mois d'avril le mois de juillet
pardon mais c'est bien que cette reprise
existent mais il aurait fallu la
compagnie plus tôt il ya aujourd'hui des
entreprises qui sont mortes depuis ces
deux dernières années qui sont des
entreprises françaises qui aurait pu
fabriquer des choses dont on a besoin
le théâtre le textile est délocalisée et
puis emmanuel macron et quand même il
sait pas les faire insulte dans une
philosophie ni de de logis du 2e de la
société qui est de la délocalisation
aujourd'hui on produit en france 20% des
médicaments qui étaient 80% ya vingt ans
donc ça c'est son école de pensée qui
l'a produit donc soit ils se déjugent
totalement mais la problématique c'est
qu'il s'est présenté pour ça donc si il
nous dit qu'en fait tout ce pour quoi il
était élu et l' inverse de ce qu il nous
faut
eh bien il faut qu'il démissionne non
mais pas uniquement qu'il fasse
l'inversé parce que visiblement il ne
sait pas faire autant se laisser faire
les gens qui savent faire
et je crois qu'à des soignants qui
savent aujourd'hui c'est dont ils ont
besoin et qu'un conseil national par
exemple des soignants serait peut-être
louable et qu'on écoute un peu plus des
soignants les séances aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée était absolument aberrant
qu'un des centres parce qu'encore une
fois on n'écoute pas les soignants et on
ne prend pas les décisions attend et on
répond par des périphrases et par de la
novlangue orwellienne alors que là on
parle d'urgence est mort alors justement
demain il ya le premier ministre edouard
philippe et le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand qui seront auditionnés à
l'assemblée nationale une audition
inédite mais pas à charge est ce que
c'est un exercice nécessaire aujourd'hui
c'est un exercice évidemment nécessaire
parce qu'il faut qui s'il écoute c'est
nécessaire après ils sont auditionnés et
cette commission présidée par yves
richard ferrand la blague est bonne
c'est une bonne vanne mais ce n'est pas
une commission qui est extrêmement
sérieuse par contre il ya des séances à
l'assemblée et la séance d'aujourd'hui
est encore importante parce que on parle
de crise sanitaire les soignants déjà
s'organise
il mène une vie face au second on parle
de héros et sert à ça fait des années
qu'on les soutient ces soignants alors
qu'ils sont gazés par le gouvernement et
qui sont tapés dessus et confrontent
absents leur régime de retraite par
exemple ça il ne faudra jamais l'oublier
par contre mais aujourd'hui une autre
crise est une crise sociale qui va se
préparer à la fin du mois d'avril qui va
être absolument monstrueuse y aura plus
de 2 millions de français qui ont été
précipitées dans la pauvreté
du jour au lendemain les loyers des hlm
ne sont toujours pas suspendu tous les
auto-entrepreneurs ces deux millions de
personnes voilà leur leur revenu
s'effondrer et de n'avoir plus aucun
revenu du jour au lendemain 5 millions
de demandeurs d'emplois qui vont se
retrouver aussi en plus grande précarité
donc c'est on n'a déjà plus digne en
cours en france on va être à 12 ou 13
millions à la fin du mois prochain
les gens qui ne font pas payer leur
loyer qui prend pas s'acheter à manger
et sommiers tout ça vous avez des sans
abri des gens dans la précarité qui
vivent aujourd hui de la solidarité qui
ne pourront plus le faire demain parce
que les gens qui aujourd'hui les aides
ce sont les gens qui ont le moins de
moyens et eux non plus donc donc la
crise sociale qui ce qui ce qui est qui
s'installent là va être absolument
incroyable et on ne sait toujours pas
comment la surmonter parce que le
gouvernement anticipe absolument rien
donc
ces auditions sont nécessaires mais
s'ils écoutent ce qu'on leur dit s'il
écoute les réalités du terrain qu'ils
écoutent les soignants si j'écoute les
associations qui sont déjà toutes en
train de crever à cause des lois qui
sont faites
et pendant ce temps-là lisf n'a pas été
le cicr n'a toujours pas été réaffecté à
l'urgence sanitaire et on a darmanin qui
fait la quête qui lance un dos circus et
la république de l'aumône alors que on
parle de solidarité la solidarité c'est
de prendre l'argent dont on a besoin là
où il est et les soignants ont très bien
entré à une photo qui circule en ce
moment où il parle de honte parce que
les moyens ne sont pas affectés c'est
pas que le l'hôpital dont on parle on
parle des femmes battues on parle des
gens isolés aujourd'hui le racisme
explose et demain quand les loyers hlm
les gens ne prend plus les payer
on va avoir une vague de vols de
violences parce que la crise sociale va
être vraiment mais c'est demain on parle
pas d'eux dans six mois ce que la crise
on va mettre longtemps à s'en remettre
c'est une évidence mais là le moins
prochain on aura d'autres sujets qui ne
sont toujours pas prêts non appréhendée
par le gouvernement ils sont encore en
train de commander des masques donc je
vois vraiment pas comment ils vont
pouvoir s'en sortir à partir moment où
on n'anticipe pas donc il va falloir
prendre des moyens un peu plus violent
institutionnellement économiquement mais
pas sur les plus pauvres
on ne sait pas faire des quêtes c'est
pas faire des dons c'est pas faire des
campagnes de recueil de dons en ligne
il va falloir très vite rétablir le cic
e et 13 e lles pardon et très vite
déclenché les vrais mécanique de
solidarité ruissellement qui ont été
détruites par mâcon depuis deux ans
merci ludovic de large pour vos propos
qui n'engagent que vous je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en communication